ومن الصراع العسكري الى صراع اخر سيظل في
صلب المعركه بين روسيا واوكرانيا حتى لو
اجل لما بعد هدوء المعارك الحديث هنا عن
حرب الاموال والذي تبدو فيه روسيا تحت
الضغط اكثر من خصمتها الاوكرانيه بالتاكيد
فمستوى صراع بين الطرفين تجاوز حدود فرض
العقوبات وتزويد كيف بالاسلحه بل امتد الى
حد التفكير في استخدام الاموال المجمده
الفكره طرحت من جديد على لسان رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي شارل الذي حث زعماء دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي على الاوروبي قدما في محادثات
بشان استخدام اصول البنك المركزي الروسي
الغايه من استخدامه هذه الاصول اعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا بعد الدمار الذي تعرضت له
من خلال الحرب المتوسطه على اراضيها
والجديد في مقترح المجلس الاوروبي استثمار
اربعه هذه الاصول وليس الاصول بذاتها
الاصول الروسيه في البنوك الاوروبيه
والامريكيه ايضا هي اصول مجمده وليست
مصادره وهنا يتجلى العائق الاساسي الذي
يواجه الاتحاد الاوروبي
فالتجميد يعني ان الاصول والممتلكات تعود
الى اصحابها بمجرد رفع العقوبات من قبل
الدوله التي فرضتها في المقام الاول اما
مصادره الاصول فهي عمليه اكثر تعقيدا
وتتطلب الحصول على اذن قضائي بعد اثبات ان
هذه الاموال استخدمت في نشاط غير قانوني
ويبدو ان الاتحاد الاوروبي على درايه بهذه
الاشكاليه وهو ما يمكن تفسيره لسعيه
لاستثمار الاصول وليس الاستفاده منها بشكل
مباشر على اي حال ان الفكره ليست بالجديده
حيث طرحت من طرف اورسو لافندر لاين رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه
الممثل الاعلى للسياسه الخارجيه وهم
اللذان اكد سابقا على ضروره التفكير في
الموضوع بشكل جدي الامر كذلك في الولايات
المتحده حيث كانت وزاره العدل الامريكيه
اكدت ان واشنطن تعتزم البدء في نقل الاصول
المصادره من روسيا لصالح اوكرانيا
وفي حال تصرف في الاموال الروسيه فان ذلك
سيكل سابقه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن
الامر ليس كذلك في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واشنطن تتحكم في اصول بمليارات
الدولار مملوكه للمصري في المركزي
الافغاني وذلك لتعويض ضحايا هجمات ال 11
من سبتمبر 2001 ولتامين مساعده انسانيه
للبلاد وهو المثال الذي يستند اليه
المدافعون عن الفكره داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي غير ان بعض معارضين الفكره يخشون
من ان تؤثر سلبا في السمعه الماليه
للاتحاد الاوروبي لا سيما فيما يتعلق
بالاحتياطات الاجنبيه كما ان هذه الخطوه
تتعارض مع القوانين الاوروبيه وهو ما اكده
وزير الشؤون الاقتصاديه السويسري
الاصول الروسيه المجمده الى اوكرانيا
سيكون انتهاكا للقانون